we are gonna begin here this morning
with some breaking news from overnight
tragedy over the skies of Hawaii all
nine people aboard a twin-engine plane
were killed when their aircraft went
down near Dillingham airfield on the
north shore of the island of Oahu the
plane burst into flames when it hit the
ground it had been used in a skydiving
flight the Honolulu Fire Chief says
family members of those on board were
nearby and most likely saw that plane go
down it is very difficult in my 40 years
as a firefighter here in Hawaii this is
the most tragic aircraft incident that
we have we had some helicopters with the
military but this is a civilian plane
that went down in the tappety people on
board witnesses say the plane appear to
have problems during takeoff noticing
that it was unsteady on the runway a
skydiving instructor told our Honolulu
affiliate KGMB there were three students
five skydivers and one pilot aboard that
plane federal air safety investigators
will now try to determine the cause of
that crash